now the government has said it will
appeal against the High Court's decision
to give Parliament as say over when
article 50 is invoked so what happens
now
could the Supreme Court vote overturn
the whole ruling well I'm joined now
from from stratford-upon-avon in actual
fact by a Michael Mansfield very good to
talk to you Michael first of all your
reaction to the reactions so to speak
and if it does go to the Supreme Court
it is upheld there do you think the
government ought to or to say something
that it will abide by whatever decision
they come to and the term really tabloid
shouldn't criticize judges well firstly
I think I'm appalled by certain well I
hesitate to call them newspapers but the
tabloids in particular the Daily Mail
it's totally irresponsible because the
judges whether you like them or you
don't like them it's beside the point
they are an independent arm of our state
they are there and they are entitled to
pass judgement on questions of law which
is what they've just done so I think
that all that that does is Flay you know
the flames of prejudice are fanned by
that kind of headline so that I'm very
dismayed and disappointed that the
government itself hasn't come out to
defend the judiciary over this secondly
I think the government at this point
should recognize that it's most unlikely
that the Supreme Court are going to go
eight they could do but to go against
three extremely senior judges including
the Lord Chief Justice it's possible but
most unlikely because it was a unanimous
judgment and a very clear judgment
almost saying we don't understand the
argument here because you know we have
parliamentary sovereignty and really
everybody recognizes that of course it
could be appealed beyond that couldn't
it be rather ironic if it ended up in
European Court yeah well there is you're
quite right there is a European Court of
Justice in Luxembourg
which deals with points of law or
interpretation of European Union law
and I don't think even if it got to the
Supreme Court that issues at the Supreme
Court will invoke European law so I
think it's unlikely it but it would be
ironical that it can get to the European
Court now just tell us I mean you know
the the the point of law here and we
want your expertise on this Michael
Mansfield
Lord Coe has involved centrally involved
in actually inserting article 50 into
the Lisbon Treaty seems to have been
saying that you actually could revoke it
you could untrue it after having
triggered it and wasn't this what the
whole case hinged on that it was
irrevocable yes yes I think I think it
valid from that point of view because
you've got parliamentary sovereignty
clearly the government and there all
sorts of things that are possible I mean
the first thing is obviously this
government in having triggered it next
March would then have to have had before
that happens some form of legislation
that's what the court is saying so
between now and March
they'll have to be a statute or they'll
have to be a piece of legislation to
draft it which authorizes the government
to trigger article 50 however however
having done that obviously one of the
other things that may is thinking about
is well let's have a general election
change the complexion of the House of
Commons so that she can be sure that if
there's a vote in relation to a statute
being passed through to trigger article
50 she'll win it clearly I think that's
one of the Dane that one of the dangers
she's worried about
but of course future Parliament's
because of parliamentary sovereignty can
undo everything it's just if you like a
protocol that successive governments
don't do that because they recognize
what they doing very often because they
recognize that it would be undermining
parliamentary sovereignty in this case
seriously undermining the will of the
British people so I think although it's
possible it's unlikely so do you think
taking all that on board that Teresa may
can stick to her timetable if she says
puts a fairly simple bill before the
House of Commons even if the supreme
caught uphold the decision she could
still trigger article 50 by the end of
March I think she could and I think what
what I think is dismaying if I can use a
puff on the word it really displays
everybody that this hadn't been thought
through probably by anyone but even once
Teresa may became prime minister she
must have known about the possibility of
parliamentary sovereignty I mean she's a
parliamentarian
and it seems to me they've got hundreds
of lawyers who drafted s nation to draft
an act which can be two lines which
authorizes the government to trigger
article 50 that's all it does he can
focus on that could have been drafted in
July they could have had a vote when
Parliament reassembled in the autumn and
they probably at this stage looking at
the way the Labor Party and opposition
parties are saying we're not going to go
against the British people on this one
so we're not we're not going to block
that vote she'd have got it through by
now so she could easily have got it and
she should still do it I think by March
the 17th I think the date is thank you
very much indeed for your input there
Michael Michael Mansfield there in
stratford-upon-avon